little donors Mom and Pops people like
my my parents and my you know other
relatives they say oh Lindsey Graham
needs money you know let's give him some
money I like him I saw him on television
and suddenly they're like signed up
forever to keep getting emails from
every Republican in the universe and
they can't stop it
the puppy will die you know your mom
will be held hostage like the messages
are so abusive and then big dollar
donors are really sick of giving their
five million 10 million 50 million
dollar checks and we don't win elections
I mean that's not what they're there for
so pretty much nobody is satisfied with
the status quo except a significant
percentage of the members of the
Republican National Committee who have
their power their privilege their title
their Prestige their photographs of
politicians I'm not there for that I'm
here to win elections so I can go back
and enjoy my life
foreign
okay so speaking of a revolution now
let's talk about what what your plans
are to do with the Republicans one of
the lines that I say on this show all
the time is you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
and I I think that's really resonated
with an awful lot of people that the
Democrats have lost their mind the
Republicans it's messy they're going to
fail you sometimes but at least there's
something there to work with so what
would your vision be of what the
Republican Party would truly stand for
you hit on a little bit of it earlier
but what's what's the real Vision that
that you want to sell to the party well
first of all you should be a republican
if you're not a Democrat
you should not I feel like that let me
just put that on the table um it is a
zero-sum game they're two parties that
are relevant in this country and if
you're not winning you're losing that's
that's the fact of politics Okay so
um with respect to what I would do
differently they're I mean we probably
don't even have time here but look the
the party has evolved in a certain
direction it's really been the same to
people running it for the last 12 years
the base of the party is revolution has
changed in a revolutionary way during
those 12 years
some of the same staff from the reince
priebus era of six years are still
running the show at the RNC today and
guess what those staff are doing they're
negotiating contracts that are
self-interested hundreds of millions of
dollars has flown into the pockets of
consultants over the last few years and
we haven't won elections the Democrats
don't operate that way the Democrats
smartened up after losing elections and
paying a bunch of money to Consultants
almost 20 years ago and they said no no
we're not going to do that anymore the
party will only do the stuff that only
the party can do and the party is plays
a very important role they have certain
uh role with respect to sharing data
with State parties with respect to
fundraising with respect to you know
worries they have certain role but a lot
of the stuff the Democrats do is outside
the party they do it in non-profits
pseudo nonprofits Pacs and whatever but
still the messaging is led by a party
apparatus that is disciplined
on focused on messaging and on their
goals they do not you know have little
disputes with each other in the in the
press and members of Congress attacking
each other that doesn't happen or they
have a party discipline and they
ruthlessly collect money and dump it
into our races and we sit here and say
as a Republican party oh sorry I will
say we can't do anything about that I'm
not saying that the party should be
picking candidates in a primary but what
I am saying is you're foolish if you let
the Democrats pick your candidates in
the primary we have no plan for that the
election laws were changed on a
wholesale basis in 2012
increment for that our party was not
raising or spending money on Election
litigation we were like oh oh there's an
election let's have some itinerant you
know temp lawyers put down their laptops
and work like a lawyer militia and work
for free to save elections for two weeks
and then go back to their jobs it
doesn't work that way we have jobs we
have commitments you can't just like
make me work for free for two weeks so
we have to have been investing like the
Democrats did in lawyers like Mark Elias
who has funded to the tune of whatever
he wants and files frivolous lawsuits
sometimes and just spams the courts with
nonsense lawsuits but they get through
and they win if there's no opposition we
have not been doing that until the last
two years I will say the chair listen to
me jumping up and down and screaming
about it we began to invest in that
issue we're still way behind
our cost of fundraising Dave is out of
control it's like 40 percent okay I just
came from a turning point USA event
turning points cost of fundraising now
it's a non-profit
seven percent or so they raise hundreds
of millions of dollars over the same
time period that we have where's that
other 30 going what's going on there
it's going into the pockets of people
who are not helping us win elections I'm
very passionate about this
little donors Mom and Pops people like
my my parents and my you know other
relatives they say oh Lindsey Graham
needs money you know let's give them
some money I like him I saw him on
television and suddenly they're like
signed up forever to keep getting emails
from every Republican in the universe
and they can't stop it
the puppy will die you know your mom
will be held hostage like the messages
are so abusive and then big dollar
donors are really sick of giving their
five million 10 million 50 million
dollar checks and we don't win elections
I mean that's not what they're there for
so pretty much nobody is satisfied with
the status quo except a significant
percentage of the members of the
Republican National Committee who have
their power their privilege their title
their Prestige their photographs with
politicians I'm not there for that I'm
here to win elections so I can go back
and enjoy my life and so
um
we would be making one of the things
that really ratcheted up the ugliness in
this race day will be very interesting
to know that I think on day three of my
campaign I tweeted that I would initiate
a top to bottom audit of every
Consulting and vendor contract at the
RNC and before that it was a very
genteal exchange of ideas and isn't it
cute that our meets running suddenly
every political consultant in DC is out
for my blood placing hit pieces
um but it's all going to come out it's
all going to come out what's been going
on there and then we can talk about what
we do about it because the Democrats
don't have this rotten corrupt system
that like we do and look a lot of people
in our RNC most of them are well-meaning
but they don't control what's going on
there and so I think I've had some
conversations with members who've been
shocked to hear what I've said and I
think I changed their minds because you
know it's a very top-down organization
the RNC tells the states if you want us
to subsidize a particular walk app or
method of fundraising when read you have
to use our system
no choice we don't give you a choice as
to what works better in your state
that's not Republican the Republican is
is pushing power down to the people it's
respecting the people it's not calling
them names some of my fellow members of
these are
called voters low information bitchers
for daring to contact them about this
leadership race I love hearing from
those voters I don't call them names
like that they're voters they may be
angry sometimes they are but they're
angry for a good reason because they're
Republicans and we don't want elections
so of course they're angry I'm angry so
um I think it is with a relatively
simple platform that I've been laying
out as I'm talking to the 168 167 other
voters but I'm also sharing that with
the with the public and there is
virtually no support for the current
leadership outside the RNC and the
consultant class who who feed off of us
and so that's been heartening and so one
way or the other we're going to see
change at the RNC right I mean I agree
with the premise there it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of support there but
for whatever reason and people can call
it the swamp or the the Deep state or
whatever the hell it is it does keep
going so The Outsiders like you always
have that that uphill battle I I see
sort of two parts of this you're talking
about sort of the under the hood
technical stuff like that that are the
problems in terms of voting and what's
going on with fundraising but I think
there's also the ideal level that it
seems like there's a real problem
Brewing just in the last couple days uh
I heard Mitch McConnell say that the
number one issue on Republicans Minds uh
is defending Ukraine from Russia and I
thought man you know I'm for the first
time in my life since I moved to Florida
I registered as a republican but I think
the ideas I talk about resonate with a
lot of people on both sides it's like
that's not in my top 20. and the way he
said it I thought man I can now see why
Republican you know the OG Republicans
have just had it with you guys what do
you do about the messaging part that
seems very disconnected when he could be
talking about I don't know the economy
the Border Free Speech Etc
well I can't do anything about Mitch
McConnell if I if I were in the United
States Senate I'd be voting for a
different leader
I can't do anything about the leadership
race in the house where because we
didn't do that well there was no Red
Wave you have this infighting that's
just awful friends of mine are throwing
stones at each other
unfortunate but I can do something about
the RNC and the RNC does set the
messaging and unfortunately we've been
kind of Hostage to whatever happened
recently whatever the Democrats said
recently we're always like reacting to
that we don't seem to be going back to
our platform or our basic values or
frankly even taking a poll and then
talking about what Republicans actually
care about we spend Millions during this
chairs tenure there have been millions
of dollars spent on Consultants on
messaging issues believe it or not and
what you see is the result of that uh
it's not very good messaging I'm sorry
to say sorry to offend the people who
are probably going to be very angry and
set out more hit pieces about me because
of that but it's true our base does not
like or appeal the messaging did not
turn out voters the candidates did not
turn out voters and and we sat there
like sitting ducks spending a bunch of
money on them and you know some of these
can't like I said back to the issue the
left to find our candidates we're
letting that happen because we're not
doing a good job of picking them and
defining them there's no party maybe
there needs to be more of a like cabal
situation where you get together and say
look guys we're not going to win in
Georgia we're not going to win in
Pennsylvania we're not going to win in
the state or that state if we don't have
a candidate who fits this profile that
means our data has to be good our um our
messaging has to be good we have to have
enough money and we have to be doing
litigation Around the Clock
election Integrity is not a seasonal
itinerant worker deal it happened I mean
you know RNC is laid off most of its
election Integrity Staff after the
election as if they're like we picked
the crop and now we're done no no we
need to be doing we are so far behind
the left we need to be doing this for a
decade or two to until we reverse the
tide and we need to be spending 10x what
we're spending on it if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell